[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça vous vous ne buvez pas de
vingt
balais juste un petit verre
fait patent bras besoin aujourd'hui
bon alors juste pour trinquer
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu es malade
ce sont des phrases que vous avez
peut-être déjà entendu ou même dit eh
bah dorénavant abstenez vous il est tout
à fait légitime de refuser du vin en
société oui oui je vous assure même en
valais
et ça sans avoir besoin de justifier
aucune raison quelle qu'elle soit
comme entrée en matière pour une
spécialiste on va c'est un peu
particulier joue la corde mais alors
c'est vrai que pour moi au nom de tous
les vignerons
si vous en buvez on préfère d'ailleurs
ceux parmi vous dans la salle qui ne
boivent pas de vin vous pouvez sortir
les housses non la voix sur ce coup là
restait tout ça si
il prend des libertés déjà non rester
assis ce que je voulais dire c'est que
le va vous avez c'est un breuvage
captivant que je défends et je contrôle
promouvoit avec coeur et conviction mais
si vous décidez de ne pas en boire libre
à vous par contre si vous restez éloigné
du vin parce que c'est un monde qui vous
semblent nébuleux compliqué réservé à
ceux qui savent là je suis pas d'accord
vous avez peut-être peur d'émettre une
critique sur 1,20 par souci de recevoir
finalement un commentaire une critique
mais tu peux pas trouver bon ce vin
aucune complexité pas de structure et
les iroquois elle est nulle et la même
pas détecté le goût du bouchon tu crois
pas il a choisi cette bouteille juste
parce que l'étiquette était jolie
alors ceux qui savent où qui croyais
savoir
merci dorénavant de s'abstenir de
dénigrer toute personne qui pourrait
émettre un commentaire sur un vin qui
apprend qui peut être se trompe et qui
surtout choisi une bouteille à son goût
et non pas aux autres peut-être que
l'univers du vin vous semble vous semble
impressionnant peut-être regarder
inaccessible voir désuet le bouquet de
sewen rappelle les bégonias en fleurs à
l'aube d'un matin d'été n'est ce pas mme
hedegaard voulez-vous bien me servir une
coupe de champagne cette robe ambrée ou
reflet d'un jaune perle du sahara et
remarqua ne trouvez vous parle ce parfum
marie-odile ne vous évoque-t-il pas le
poulain vrech mener ses bâtons dans les
prés
ça aussi c'est fini le vin est un
produit simple il est issu de la terre
il est convivial il est passionnant il
est sympathique donc pourquoi vouloir
faire quelque chose de compliqué et je
vous assure en suisse la jeunesse
vigneronne qui est en place et qui
arrive à bordes le vin de maintenir
novatrice est tout à fait branché
pourtant en plus dans la dégustation on
est d'accord chacun ses perceptions
chacun son avis les goûts sont d'une
diversité infinie pourtant dans mon
travail je rencontre quand même
fréquemment des gens à qui je dis que
pensez vous de cette petite arvine au
bon j'en sais rien molveau jusqu'en
époque où la fameuse question qui fait
un peu peur vous dégustez a alors non
alors moi je ne sais pas fait plus tôt
déguster mon voisin lui lui connaît
et c'est là que finalement sachez que
votre voisin il est tout aussi
embarrassé que vous même donc il est
temps de faire confiance à vos papilles
et de déguster le vin avec avec joie et
est en vie
j'aimerais vous le proposez d'une
manière un petit peu différente admettez
que vous dégustez le vin de même manière
que vous aborderez un autre produit
aliments ou boissons
admettons je vous soumets 3 limonade
citron ou peu importe trois pains
différents 3 yogourt fraises différent
et je vous demande un avis voire un
classement vous n'allez pas me répondre
un long mois la limonade citron
je suis pas trop sûr non alors qu'en
fait vous êtes absolument pas
spécialiste en limonade citron si ça se
trouve vous n'en buvait jamais enfin si
je crois que le monsieur que là en bas à
droite il est spécialiste audio gucht en
l'occurrence non mais la technique qui
vous pouvez couper là la voix off enfin
moi je dis ça j'ai juste pour dire que
reprenons je vous soumets mais yogourt
fraises sans complexe même si vous
n'êtes pas fada do you want 13 vous
allez me donner un classement vous allez
me dire ah ben oui je préfère le numéro
2 parce que sa couleur elle semble plus
naturels sont parfois il est plus
intense ça la texture elle est onctueuse
à mais par contre le numéro 3 oui il a
quand même un peu moins de sucre un peu
plus de deux bouts de morceaux de fruits
donc finalement et cetera et cetera donc
il n'y a pas du tout de blocage donc
pourquoi avec le vin tout d'un coup il
ya quelque chose qui coince alors
j'avoue que d'une fois j'avais soumis ma
théorie du lourd 13 à un ami il m'a dit
oui mais il ya quand même nettement
moins de mystère
qui entoure un humour de fraises qu'une
bouteille de vin
quoi qu'on serait surprise un des
mystères que renferme le yogourt mais il
a peut-être raison sur ce sur ce point
là mais finalement mois ci un verre de
vin vous fait plus rêver qu'un pot de
yaourt je suis assez contente donc
laissons lui un brin de mystère à ce va
et dégustons joyeusement pas sont
d'ailleurs aux choses sérieuses
[Rires]
jean sérieuse
voilà voilà où pouvoir qui se
matérialise
je vais vous donner quelques conseils
pour bien déguster le vin et faire en
tout cas comme si vous étiez des pros
c'est facile deux trois petites choses
qui fait que ça marche le ver simplement
vous le tenez par le pied regardez je
déguste
je bois un coup
se déguste
ces petits détails mais ça fait toute
l'histoire ensuite quand vous voulez
faire le fameux geste de l'oenologue ça
on fait juste pour amener de l'air dans
le var et pics à l'arrière un petit peu
si vous n'avez pas le chic vous tournez
sur la table comme ça et puis aussi on
évite justement le tournée de coude las
autre petit détail jamais servir à
l'envers toujours servir comme ça on est
d'accord puisque je vais pas le faire
sinon ça va faire des catastrophes mais
à l'époque on avait moyen de mettre un
peu de poison dans une grosse bague et
puis en fait en versant le liquide chez
le voisin on pouvait éventuellement
l'empoisonner donc c'est plus tellement
d'actualité mais ça veut quand même
signifié que vous voulez finalement pas
du bien à cette personne donc important
servir dans le bon sens
ensuite quelques notions de dégustation
la couleur la robe la teinte on peut
faire les choses compliquées et cité 12
couleur le rose et de patagonie ou je ne
sais pas mais en même temps le but est
de regarder le vin qu'on ait envie de le
boire il est jaune il est brillant il
est limpide y'a pas de problème le
parfum gros morceau le parfum on a
l'impression que pour être grand
dégustateur il faut absolument cité 5
fruits et légumes au minimum
alors qu'en fait imaginez plutôt un
paysage est ce que c'est quelque chose
de frais quelque chose de lourd est ce
que vous êtes au bord d'un torrent est
ce que c'est un souvenir de vacances est
ce que vous êtes plutôt dans la forêt
avec de la terre etc non plutôt un
paysage et sachez que pour dédramatiser
aussi la situation
si vous sentez une odeur très forte
admettant le cassis
passé le petit moment de gloire où vous
dites et ça sent le cassis et puis que
tout le monde dit ah ouais t'as raison
en fait c'est pas une preuve de ce n'est
pas une preuve que le vin est magnifique
puisque déjà c'est du jus de raisin et
puis vaut mieux avoir 10 odeur
différente non identifiée c'est une
preuve de complexité plutôt que cette
fameuse odeur de cassis qui sera
peut-être la preuve d'un vin simple et
peut être linéaire
ensuite vous le prenez en bouche une
gorgée normal vous allez le balader un
petit peu trois à cinq secondes dans
votre bouche ça vous permettra de vous
faites un peu comme vous brosser les
dents mais avec un peu plus de finesse
peut-être quand moore a scellé dans
vous le balader dans votre bouche alors
bien sûr on va regarder les saveurs de
base c'est-à-dire sucré salé acide amer
est ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui me
parlent qui est équilibrée tout en
sachant que vous n'êtes pas tous
configurés la même chose au niveau du
palais et selon les habitudes des
personnes non sentir l'acidité fortement
et d'autres d'autres pas du tout et
c'est donc ces saveurs de base est
souvent la petite clé qui fait qu'on
déguste mieux le vin c'est que le sens
qu'on oublie toujours c'est le toucher
alors bien sûr vous allez pas commencé à
mettre le doigt dedans mais les touches
et tactile qu'est-ce qui se passe et une
fois que vous avez compris ça vous allez
comprendre les gens qui vous parle du
vin quand on vous parle d'un vin qui est
corsée pierron qui en qui érige qui est
dense qui est tendu c'est pas une
histoire de goût c'est toute une
histoire de texture alors la prochaine
fois vous prenez cela et vous
réfléchissez aux textures de ce vin est
là on va chercher une harmonie et le
dernier point finalement
persistance de goût est-ce que ça me
laisse en bouche un joli souvenir est ce
que j'ai envie de reprendre mon verre ou
et contre au contraire et j'ai mes
papilles qui reste tout tout crispé et
puis que on n'a plus envie de revoir ce
ver donc vous vos jugements sont tout à
fait tout à fait juste le dernier sens
que je n'ai pas abordé c'est louis alors
là aussi les bruits du vin sont
intéressants sont sympathiques l'appel à
l'apéritif
ça c'est le point positif par contre
méfiez vous quand quelqu'un dit la
fameuse question vous dégustez si la
personne répond waouh ça c'est une
magnifique petite arvine vous êtes tout
les guides qui peut mettre le curseur
sur j'ai dégusté quelque chose de bon et
ah ouais t'as raison à ce qu'elle est
bonne cette petite arvine
tant mieux ça c'est positif par contre
si la première personne elle me répond à
qui quand même un peu acide cette petite
arvine de nouveau toute l'équipe ah
ouais t'as raison donc méfiez vous parce
qu'elle est peut-être acide pour le
premier n'est pas pour vous donc aux
mêmes dire ah ben non moi je trouve
qu'elle est bien elle a une belle
nervosité vivacité vie c'est le joli mot
pour dire acide si jamais
des lives a cité et vous dites vous
aimez ça vous verrez vous êtes la moitié
de la salle qui dit ah ouais bah en fait
moi aussi je les aime bien donc méfiez
vous un petit peu de tout ce qui se dit
sur sur ces vins et écouter vos
perceptions
d'une fois que vous savez déguster ou
plutôt vous décider une fois pour toutes
de faire confiance à vos perceptions
mais à tous dégustent la même chose
le café le chocolat le fromage le fameux
you court 13 et donc on peut s'exprimer
et donner notre ressenti
petite parenthèse professionnelle
on est d'accord les goûts personnels
c'est bien vous imaginez quand même que
si je doit juger un vin
pour le classer éventuellement lui
décerner une médaille ou un prix ou quoi
que ce soit je peux pas m'asseoir à la
table des petite arvine et admettons que
je n'aime pas la petite arvine recalés
tous les vins parce que c'est pas parce
que je préfère janice on est d'accord
donc la dégustation professionnelle y
aura toujours une petite part de
subjectivité mais par contre il ya un
vocabulaire spécifique à des critères
établis sur lesquels on peut se baser
est typiquement la couleur est ce qu
elle correspond aux cépages au milieu m
le parfum est ce qu'il est représentatif
du cépage est ce qu'il est intense et ce
qu'il est complexe est ce qu'il ya des
défauts oenologique éventuellement la
bouche est ce qu'elle est harmonieuse
est ce qu'il ya une persistance et c'est
donc là je vais mettre mes cochons ok le
bouquet superbe la couleur ok je remplis
tout mais koch je peux donner une
magnifique note un vin mais par contre
pas forcément avoir envie de le boire
mais dans la vie courante
le vin doit uniquement être un plaisir
et vous pouvez donner votre avis vous
est légitime de le donner et rappelez
vous aussi si vous regardez les enfants
combien c'est naturel pour un enfant de
regarder toucher sentir en danger c'est
même embêtant quand ils veulent
absolument manger leur légaux ou
déguster le petit ver de terre qui se
promène dans le jardin mais juste pour
dire que c'est finalement inea chaque à
d'incessants ce donc il suffit des fois
juste un peu de lait les réactiver et
faire confiance à ce qu'on a ce qu'on
ressent
petit clin d'oeil dans la vie en général
peu importe le sujet il est des fois
aussi bon de se rappeler que celui ou
celle qui parle le plus fort et le plus
dans une assemblée où sur les réseaux
n'est pas celui ou celle qui a forcément
raison donc on peut aussi se manifester
oui selon les sujets il faut aussi des
fois peut être nous mêmes savoirs nous
taire juste écouter se renseigner et
continuer d'apprendre
est dorénavant
à la fameuse question vous dégustez
votre réponse sera oui et avec plaisir
[Applaudissements]